[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Heinz
Wolf und Marietta
slonka guten Abend das lief heute in
Berlin etwas anders als erwartet
eigentlich hatte es nach einer
vorbereiteten Choreografie ausgesehen
die schon am Freitag begonnen hatte mit
dem Mittagessen zwischen Kanzler Scholz
und Oppositionsführer märz das so wurde
ja ausdrücklich betont in sehr
konstruktivever Atmosphäre stattgefunden
habe die Erwartungshaltung für den Bund
ländergipfel heute war nun folgende die
Unionsländer und die SPD Länder sitzen
in Berlin mittags zusammen die
wesentlichen Punkte bereits im Vorfeld
abgesprochen und dann geht es recht
flott ins Kanzleramt um dort gemeinsam
Druck beim Thema Finanzen zu machen
damit der Bund für die
flüchtlingsbetreuung mehr zahlt doch wie
gesagt der Tag verlief etwas anders
Klass brotbeck berichtet aus Berlin
eigentlich alles klar
16:1 die Länder gegen den Bund alle
gegen einen das war der Plan eigentlich
doch statt vier Stunden wie vorgesehen
saßen die ministerpräsidentinnen und
Ministerpräsidenten fast acht
beieinander statt zu beraten wurde
kräftig gestritten
ähm Grund besteht darin dass wir ja vor
di Wochen eine Sitzung in Frankfurt
hatten die mit einem sehr guten
Beschluss zum Thema
Migration Flucht und Asyl zu Ende
gegangen ist und zwar einvernehmlich und
die sogenannten a-länder also die SPD
regierten Länder einschließlich
Thüringen sind heute überrascht worden
von umfassenden Änderungsvorschlägen der
sogenannten B Länder also der
unionsregierten Länder und
waden-württemberg die teilwe Weise die
Ergebnisse unserer damaligen Runde in
Frage gestellt haben und darüberus auf
weitere Themen aufgemacht haben ich will
zugestehen dass man mit solchen Punkten
früher auf seinen Partner zukommt da
will ich überhaupt gar nicht um den
heißen prier rum ren aber auch in der
Union gibt's natürlich Diskussionen
darüber ob man diesen oder jeden Punkt
gerne als Priorität setzen möchte und
diese Diskussionen haben eben auch etwas
länger gedauert gehen sollte es ursprüng
vor allem um mehr Geld vom Bund jährlich
1,25 Milliarden Euro fordern die Länder
dazu eine Pauschale von 10500 € pro
geflüchteten und Jahr und weitere 1,4
Milliarden Kostenerstattung für die
Unterbringung das bisherige Angebot des
Bundes nach 3,75 Milliarden in diesem
nur noch 1,25 im nächsten Jahr deutlich
drunter spät also und wenig geschlossen
treten die Länder erst am Abend vor den
Bund kaum da lenken beide Seiten vom
Streit ab verkünden lieber schnell einen
Erfolg Einigung auf beschleunigte
Planungsverfahren wir haben in den
letzten Jahrzehnten mit großer Liebe und
Zuneigung überall in Deutschland immer
mehr Vorschriften erfunden und Regelung
die am Ende dazu beigetragen haben dass
wir kaum noch in der Lage sind das ganze
Regelwerk zu beherrschen sonst hat damit
zu tun dass wir nur so und auf diese Art
und Weise und wenn wir uns im wahrsten
Sinne des Wortes beeilen und
entschlacken und
entbürokratisieren und vielfach
gulliivars Fesseln ablegen äh unseren
Wohlstand und damit natürlich auch
unsere Zukunftsfähigkeit sichern können
es tut mir fast leid dass wir heute
diesen Pakt für Beschleunigung
beschließen und zwar deswegen weil wir
natürlich auf der tagesaugen noch andere
Themen haben die wahrscheinlich morgen
in den Medien alles andere überdecken
werden Prognose genau das dürfte
geschehen
ja fragen wir unsere Korrespondentin
Diana Zimmermann in Berlin Diana da
stellt sich schon die Frage wenn man
sich diesen Ablauf dieses Tages ansieht
warum die unionsgeführten Länder plus
badenwürtemberg plötzlich mit neuen
Forderungen angereist sind und damit den
Zeitplan so durcheinander gebracht haben
ja das muss man wohl darauf zurückführen
dass sie signalisieren wollten dass sie
noch härter durchgreifen wollen bei der
Migrationsfrage als die Ampel es schon
tut die Ampel ist tatsächlich in den
letzten Wochen über einige ihrer
Schatten gesprungen das aber reicht der
Union nicht sie hat neue Forderungen
aufgestellt einige davon sind mit dem
deutschen Grundgesetz nicht zu
vereinbaren andere hat sie durchbekommen
so etwa das den begrenzten Nachzug für
Familienangehörige worauf sich die
Länderchefs trotz des sehr langen
Streites nicht einigen konnten war es
Asylverfahren in sogenannten sicheren
Drittstaaten durchzuführen Ruanda wird
ja immer wieder als Beispiel genannt da
wollten die SPD Ministerpräsidenten
nicht mitziehen man sollte es beim
Gespräch im Kanzleramt heute ja vor
allem um ums Geld gehen und das das
wird's ja wohl nun auch was was hört man
denn in Berlin wie die Verhandlungen
darüber so laufen ja da wussten wir ja
schon dass Streit ansteht denn die
Länderchefs sind sich in diesem Punkt
ausgesprochen einig sie sind der Ansicht
nur der Bund ist dafür verantwortlich
wie viel Menschen ins Land kommen und je
mehr Menschen kommen desto mehr soll der
Bund auch Zahlen der Bund dagegen
verweist auf die Schuldenbremse sagt es
sei nicht mehr Geld da und was wir hier
hören ist dass eine Einigung nicht vor
Mitternacht zu erwarten ist eine lange
Berliner Nacht danke schön Diana nach
Berlin und während im Kanzleramt noch
über den künftigen Umgang mit
Flüchtlingen gestritten wird zeigte sich
bei Demonstrationen am Wochenende dass
es auch einiges zu besprechen gibt mit
Blick auf Migration die längst
stattgefunden hat teils schon vor
Generationen nicht dass diese Erkenntnis
im politischen Raum neu wäre aber
einiges von dem was sich insbesondere in
Essen und Berlin am Samstag abspielte
hat das noch mal deutlich vor Augen
geführt anders formuliert wer meint das
Kalifat sei die Lösung kann mit
demokratischen Staatswesen offenkundig
nichts anfangen und man kann sich auch
ausmalen wie solche Bilder auf die
überschaubare Zahl jüdischer Menschen
hier zulande wirken wie die Politik
reagiert berichtet Jana
Becker sie fordern die Errichtung eines
Kalifats hisen Fahnen deren Symbole
radikal islamistischen Gruppen
alsäammlung angemeldete Demo in Essen
schlägt im Nachgang zum Wochenende bei
den Verantwortlichen in der Politik hohe
Wellen bundesinnenministerin nen Feser
sieht eine rote Linie überschritten
äußert sich heute gegenüber der dpa wir
tolerieren nicht dass ein islamischer
Gottesstaat auf unseren Straßen
propagiert wird diese Linie muss unser
rechtsstat konsequent durchsetzen mit
versammlungsverboten und hartem
polizeilichen einschreiten doch was
bringt das in der
praxisan Aktivität von denen verbieten
jeden Schriftzug verbieten und anderes
mehr aber ob die Menschen dann als Fritz
müllermeer also als normale Menschen
auftauchen das können sie nicht
verhindern in Düsseldorf hatten sich am
Samstag rund 17 000 Menschen versammelt
hier waren unter anderen Plakate zu
sehen die die aktuellen
Kriegsgeschehnisse mit dem Holocaust
gleichsetzen in Berlin nahmen inhalbus
Menschen Teil einen körperlichen Angriff
auf einen jüdischen Mann konnten Ordner
nur knapp verhindern
Ermittlungsverfahren wurden eleitet man
muss klar sagen dass Islamisten die
Ereignisse in Palästina natürlich
ausnutzen für ihre Propaganda sie sind
sozusagen drittbrettfahrer dieses
Kriegsgeschehens und versuchen natürlich
bodengewinne zu erzielen durch die
Teilnahme an solchen Demonstrationen und
klar ist aber auch dass wir darauf
hinweisen müssen dass natürlich nicht
alle Menschen die an solchen
Demonstrationen teilnehmen die
Sichtweise der Islamisten teilen die dem
Essen Gerät mit rund 3000 Teilnehmenden
in den Fokus der öffentlichen Debatte um
Hetze bei proalästina Demos Menschen
laufen mit Fahnen durch die Straßen die
denen des is und der Taliban ähneln nur
ein Ermittlungsverfahren ist bei der
Staatsanwaltschaft Essen im Nachgang zur
Demo eingeleitet worden wegen des
Verdachts der Volksverhetzung gegen den
hauptrredner die Polizei Essen geht
heute nicht vor die Presse äußert sich
lediglich in einem Statement auf X
ehemals Twitter auch wenn für uns
bestimmte Äußerungen und Auffassungen
nur schwer erträglich sind sind wir an
Recht und Gesetz gebunden wir schützen
keine Meinungen sondern unsere
Grundrechte doch welche Möglichkeiten
hat der Staat um gegen Desinformation
und Propaganda vorzugehen die Polizei
kann bei Volksverhetzung Beleidigung
schwenken von terrorfahren auch wenn sie
dem Original nur zum Verwechseln ähnlich
seinden beim begen von Straftaten
Demonstrationen auflösen und sie muss
diese Straftaten dokumentieren Person
festellen dann kann die Justiz mit Hilfe
von Schnellverfahren bei den vielen
eindeutigen Fällen innerhalb von wenigen
Tagen Anklagen und verurteilen
zusätzliche Schwierigkeiten bereitet den
Ermittlern die
onlinewt beobachten seit einigen Tagen
dort eine enorme emotionale
Mobilisierung durch Videos die Opfer aus
dem Kriegsgeschehen zeigen eine
Mobilisierung die wohl auch in der
kommenden Zeit Menschen aufhetzen und
auf die Straße wird für den Rechtsstaat
eine enorme
Herausforderung im Schatten des
nostkonflikts geht auch der Krieg in der
Ukraine unvermindert weiter letzte Nacht
haben die Russen wieder mehrere Städte
bombardiert und schwere Schäden
angerichtet damit beginnen bei dir die
Nachrichten Heinz ja die russische Armee
hat in der vergangenen Nacht auch wieder
Regionen im Süden der Ukraine mit
Raketen und Drohnen angegriffen nach
ukrainischen Angaben wurden in der
Hafenstadt Odessa acht Menschen verletzt
mehrere Wohnhäuser und das nationale
Kunstmuseum wurden beschädigt auch die
zurückeroberte Region um die Stadt
Cherson war demnach Ziel massiver
russischer
Angriffe in Polen hat Präsident duda den
amtierenden Ministerpräsidenten
moravietzki mit der Regierungsbildung
beauftragt als Kandidat der peace
parartei die war bei der Parlamentswahl
Mitte Oktober zwar stärkste Kraft
stärkste Partei geworden verfehlte aber
die absolute Mehrheit scheitert
moravieetki im Parlament könnte der
Auftrag an den ehemaligen
EU-Ratspräsidenten Tusk gehen der mit
einem Dreier Bündnis eine
Koalitionsmehrheit bilden
will der ehemalige US-Präsident Donald
Trump hat heute unter Eid in einem
Betrugsprozess gegen ihn in New York
ausgesagt sein Immobilienkonzern soll
jahrelang Zahlen beschönigt haben um
bessere Kredite und Versicherungen zu
erhalten Trump wie die schuldigungen vor
Gericht zurück und bezeichnete das
Verfahren als politische Hexenjagd ihm
droht neben einer hohen Geldstrafe auch
ein geschäftsverbot im US-Bundesstaat
New
York die in Iran inhaftierte
Friedensnobelpreisträgerin narges
Mohammadi ist in einen Hungerstreik
getreten sie habe ihrer Familie darüber
eine Nachricht aus dem berüchtigten
ewiin Gefängnis in theeran zukommen
lassen hie es in einer Mitteilung von
Angehörigen aus dem Ausland Mohammadi
protestiere mit dem Hungerstreik gegen
Haftbedingungen wie mangelnde
medizinische Versorgung und auch gegen
den Kopftuchzwang in
Iran Anfang Juni hatten das ZDF und der
Spiegel enthüllt das ehemalige
Kampfpiloten der Luftwaffe als Ausbilder
für das chinesische militärarbeiten
jetzt plant die Ampelkoalition nach
Informationen des ZDF Hauptstadtstudios
die Abwerbung von Beamten mit sensiblem
Wissen zu erschweren dazu soll zunächst
das Beamtenrecht verschärft werden
gleiches soll dann durch eine Änderung
des soldatengesetzes auch für ehemalige
Angehörige der Bundeswehr wie frühere
Kampfpiloten
gelten nach dem Geiseldrama am Hamburger
Flughafen sollen dort laut einer
Sprecherin weitere bauliche Maßnahmen
vorgenommen werden um den Zugang zum
Sicherheitsbereich zu verstärken am
Samstagabend hatte ein 35 Jahre alter
Mann im Auto eine Absperrung
durchbrochen und war auf das Vorfeld
Gefahren im Wagen saß seine vier Jahre
alte Tochter nach mehr als 18 Stunden
ergab sich der
Mann gerade in diesen Zeiten sollte man
wohl hoffen dass die Sicherheit in
Flughäfen nicht nur darin besteht
eingecheckte Passagiere zu
durchleuchten im Nahen Osten geht der
wah der Kampf Israels gegen die Hamas
weiter die diplomatischen Bemühungen der
Amerikaner für eine vorübergehende
Feuerpause zeigen bislang keine große
Wirkung die israelische Regierung sagt
dass eine Pause zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt
nur der Hamas helfen würde sich neu zu
formieren die israelische Armee gab
bekannt dass sie gazastadt mit Truppen
umstellt habe und den gesamten
Gazastreifen in zwei Teile geteilt die
im Norden noch verbliebene Bevölkerung
soll über einen Korridor in den Süden
Richtung ägyptische Grenze flöchten
henrigette de mier
berichtet ein selten friedlicher Moment
im Süden des gaz
assan sagt ihre Tochter und diese Vögel
seinen alles was ihr geblieben ist die
alte Frau nahm die Tiere mit bei ihrer
Flucht aus dem Norden in den Süden des
Gazastreifens wo ich schlafe sollen sie
bei mir sein es ist gut so als ranonis
bombardiert wurde suchte ich Nahrung für
die Vögel ich hatte keine Angst alle
Menschen hatten Angst und sagten geh
nicht doch ich ging und fand Futter für
siez Fahrzeuge der israelischen Armee
überqueren vergangene Nacht die Grenze
zum Gazastreifen liefern militärischen
Nachschub das sollen diese Bilder
belegen mit ihrem Vormarsch bis zum Meer
haben die israelischen Truppen den
Norden vom Süden getrennt am Tag
ermöglicht die Armee den Bewohnern Gazas
für mehrere Stunden auf einer sicheren
Route in den Süden zu gelangen die 18
Jahre alte Minna ist diesen Weg gegangen
lebt mit ihrer Familie seit Tagen in
ihren
Autos wir kamen in der Hoffnung
Sicherheit zu finden aber die existiert
nicht wenn wir schlafen hören wir die
Raketen über unseren Köpfen Schutz gibt
es nicht bei einem Treffen mit dem
bulgarischen Premierminister machte
israels Ministerpräsident Netanyahu
heute noch einmal die ganze
Betroffenheit Israels
deutlich wir kämpfen gegen einen Feind
der der grausamste Feind ist seit dem
Holocaust der ein doppeltes
Kriegsverbrechen begeht er nimmt nicht
nur absichtlich Zivilisten ins Visier
sondern setzt auch seine Zivilisten als
menschliche Schutzschilder ein Israel
wirft der Hamas immer wieder vor den Tod
von Zivilisten bigend in Kauf zu nehmen
auf diesen Aufnahmen soll der Eingang zu
einem Tunnel der Hamas zu sehen sein
direkt neben einem
Krankenhaus wir sind nun seit einem
Monat im Krieg gegen die Hamas und wir
fügen ihnen viele Verluste zu haben
einige aus ihrer Führung getötet und
zerstören viel der Infrastruktur der
Hamas im
Gaza
bringt sie nach Hause fordern
unterdessen auch heute die Angehörigen
der israelischen Geiseln in Jerusalem
sie fürchten um ihre
Liebsten ich bin heute für alle Geiseln
hier wir wollen dass Sie frei sind und
wir wollen wissen dass sie leben wir
wollen dass ihre Familien wissen dass
sie nicht allein
sind und wir wollen sie unterstützen und
gemeinsam mit ihnen um die Rückkehr
ihrer Kinder und Enkelkinder weinen
vermisste tote Trauer Tag 31 des Krieges
in
Israel Katrin Eigendorf ist für uns in
Israel Katrin aus telaviv uns
zugeschaltet es fällt ja doch auf wie
sehr sich die Amerikaner um eine
vorübergehende Feuerpause bemühen aber
sie haben damit keinen Erfolg in
Israel ja das fällt wirklich auf dass
dieser Erfolg immer noch ausbleibt heute
hat Präsident Joe Biden noch einmal
versucht mit Ministerpräsident Benjamin
Netanyahu ins Gespräch zu kommen er hat
mit ihm telefoniert aber auch das ist
völlig ohne Erfolg geblieben was den
Amerikanern hier große Sorge bereitet
ist dass sich die Situation immer mehr
zu einem Flächenbrand in der Region
entwickelt dass die Kritik nicht nur von
den Länder der arabischen Welt sondern
international an Israels Vorgehen im
Gazastreifen immer weiter zunimmt kritik
gibt's mittlerweile auch innerhalb der
israelischen Bevölkerung es sind vor
allem die Familien der entführten der
Geiseln die sich noch in den Händen der
Hamas befinden die sagen es muss darauf
geachtet werden dass das Leben der
Geiseln hier geschützt wird aber sowohl
das Leben der Geiseln als auch der
Schutz der palästinensischen Bevölkerung
im gaz Strafen spielt anscheinend für
die Regierung netanahu hier keine Rolle
sie scheinen wirklich entschlossen zu
sein diesen Krieg weiterzuführen und
relativ wenig Raum für humanitäre
Maßnahmen zu lassen es gibt immer wieder
mal Möglichkeiten dass humanitäre
Maßnahmen zugelassen werden aber das was
die Amerikaner eigentlich gefordert
haben nämlich eine sogenannte humanitäre
Feuerpause darüber ist mit der Regierung
Netanyahu nicht zu reden das hat die
israelische Armee ja bekanntegeben dass
es eben diese Zweiteilung des
Gazastreifens gibt was bezweckt sie
damit militärisch wie s soll es danach
weitergehen der militärische Zweck ist
dass man versuchen möchte die
Zivilbevölkerung möglichst aus den
bevorstehenden schweren Kämpfen im
Norden des Gazastreifens herauszuhalten
also man hat die Bevölkerung ja schon
mehrfach aufgefordert sich in den Süden
des gasastreifens zu bewegen dass dem
dieser Forderung sind nicht alle
nachgekommen es gibt immer noch viele
Zivilisten im Norden und das Problem ist
dass die Israel is Armee mit ihrer
Bodenoffensive jetzt gazastadt
eingezingelt hat und im Prinzip dort die
Infrastruktur der Hamas zerschlagen will
die Hamas versteckt sich aber immer
wieder in zivilen Einrichtungen in
Krankenhäusern in Kindergärten und was
man erreichen möchte ist das Zivilisten
nicht zwischen die Fronten der Kämpfe
zwischen israelischen Truppen und deras
geraten das ist im Prinzip das Ziel
dieser militärischen Zweiteilung des
Gazastreifens ein schwieriges
Unterfangen K dan danke dir nach Tel
Aviv zu den Entwicklungen im Nahen Osten
wie auch über andere weltpolitische oder
innenpolitische Themen hält sie die
übrigens die ztf heute App auf dem
Laufenden und die gibt's jetzt auch bei
Whatsapp dafür scannen Sie entweder den
angezeigten QR-Code oder sie abonnieren
ZDF heute direkt bei Whatsapp so
bekommen Sie die Nachrichtenlage immer
kompakt zusammengefasst mit Updates am
Morgen und am
Abend und jetzt geht's bei dir noch mal
weiter mit dem Blick auf die deutsche
Wirtschaft der Deutsche
Gewerkschaftsbund hat eine Kampagne für
mehr Tarifschutz angekündigt die DGB
Vorsitzende fahimi bemängelt aktuell
profitierten nur noch rund die Hälfte
aller Beschäftigten hierzulande von
tarifvertraglichen Regelungen und ihrem
Schutz und sie warnt vor den Folgen
Valerie Haller was sind die Folgen nach
Ansicht des DGB also laut DGB verdienen
die Menschen bei gleicher Tätigkeit 12%
im Schnitt weniger und stützt sich dabei
auf Daten vom Statistischen Bundesamt
außerdem bekämen sie weniger
Zusatzleistungen wie Urlaubs und
Weihnachtsgeld durch Tarifflucht
entsteht nach Analyse der Gewerkschaft
auch ein volkswirtschaftlicher Schaden
der DGB rechnet vor durch Tarifbindung
stundnden Arbeitnehmern pro Jahr rund 60
Milliarden Euro mehr zur Verfügung die
Sozialversicherungen könnten 43
Milliarden Euro mehr einnehmen und bei
der Einkommenssteuer kämen 27 Milliarden
Euro hinzu tatsächlich WD heute deutlich
weniger Menschen nach Tarif bezahlt als
früher Mitte der 90er Jahre waren es
noch fast 80% 2022 nur noch rund die
Hälfte aller Beschäftigten allerdings
gibt es in den einzelnen Branchen
riesige Unterschiede hohe Quoten weisen
öffentlicher Dienst Verteidigung und
Sozialversicherung auf ebenso
Energieversorgung geringe Quoten
hingegen haben Gastgewerbe Land und
Forstwirtschaft gegen Tarifflucht will
sich der DGB B nun stemmen Arbeitgeber
davon zu überzeugen dürfte schwierig
werden ihr Argument Tarifverträge führen
zu hörhen kosten sein überkomplex das
Tarifwerk veraltet die fehlende
Tarifbindung könnte für Firmen die
Geschäfte mit der öffentlichen Hand
machen wollen aber bald zum Problem
werden Bundesarbeitsminister Heil plant
größere Aufträge des Bundes nur noch an
Unternehmen zu vergeben die tarifzahlen
Valerie Haller vielen
Dank er als Urgestein des deutschen
Privatfernsehens und war einer der
bekanntesten Moderatoren und
Journalisten wie nun bekannt wurde ist
Hans Meiser in der vergangenen Woche
gestorben Meiser moderierte zunächst im
Hörfunk bevor er in den 1980er Jahren
als nachrichtenmoderator zum privaten
Fernsehsender RTL plus wechselte mit der
rettungssendung Notruf und seiner
nachmittags Talkshow wurde er Anfang der
90er Jahre berühmt Hans Meiser starb an
Herzversagen er wurde 77 JRE und ich
k Tennisprofi Laura Siegemund hat den
Doppelwettbewerb bei den WTA Finals im
mexikanischen kankun gewonnen gemeinsam
mit ihrer russischen Partnerin Veras
swonareva siegte die 35-Jährige Schwäbin
im Finale gegen Nicole melicaa Martinez
und Alen Peris aus den USA und
Australien in zwei Sätzen Siegemund ist
die erste deutsche Tennisspielerin die
beim Saisonabschlussturnier im Doppel
triumphieren
konnte normalerweise sind Polarlichter
nur viel weiter im Norden zu sehen in
der Nacht zum Montag haben sie den
Himmel auch über mehreren Bundesländern
zum Leuchten gebracht größere
Wolkenlücken hatten die Sicht auf das
seltene Himmelsspektakel begünstigt
besonders in ländlichen Gebieten
polarlichter entstehen wenn elektrisch
geladene Teilchen durch starke
Sonnenwinde auf das Magnetfeld der Erde
treffen ein Film feierte heute in
Hamburg Premiere von dem unsere Autorin
Barbara Luke sagt dass sie ihn uns sehr
ans Herz legt ein kleiner feiner Film
über ein sehr großes Thema wie bleibt
man zusammen als Paar über Jahrzehnte
bis ins hohe Alter warum gelingt das
manchen und anderen nicht gibt es ein
Geheimnis für Glück in der
Liebe für immer heißt der Film und es
ist kein Spielfilm sondern ein
Dokumentar ilm über ein paar aus dem
wahren Leben das geschafft hat wovon
viele nur träumen und eines sei vorweg
verraten ein ständiges Glück war auch
diese große lange Liebe
[Musik]
nicht da steht
7657 ich möchte noch lange mit dir
Zusammenleben und in ferner Zeit mit dir
zusammen
sterben vor knapp 70 Jahren tanzen und
ersten Mal miteinander und hören nie
mehr auf es ist ihr gegenseitiges
versprechen die junge Dokumentarfilmerin
Pia Lenz begibt sich auf die Spuren
dieser Ehe jahrelang ganz nah und voller
Fragen ihrer Generation was hält
Menschen zusammen wie schafft man das
was können wir lernen von den alten wir
schieben dieses altwererden irgendwie
eher so beiseite warum auch immer ich
habe das eigentlich nie so richtig
verstanden weil mich das immer
fasziniert hat also wie ist das wenn man
so lange zusammen ist was bleibt da
eigentlich der Film taucht ein in ihr
Leben in Glück und Abgründe den Tod der
Tochter
ihrbruch es geht um
Seitensprünge ich weiß bis heute nicht
ob du mit traute was angefangen
hast das habe ich gestanden
damals Schauspielerin Nina Hoss spricht
Evas Tagebuch Notizen die aus all den
Jahrzehnten erzählen Ehekrise 59 60 diet
du maulfauler Stockfisch du wortkager
Klotz du
gefühlsurneekrise es wird kommen der Tag
da bitte ich dich und deine Gefühle zur
Kasse Schönheit und Dramen ihrer Ehe
wachsen wie ein Mosaik bis ins hohe
Alter zusammen und zeigen wie es gehen
kann dieses Leben zu
zweit wie ich die beiden beobachtet habe
schaffen sie es vor allem durch die Art
und Weise wie sie einander begegnen also
dass die sich noch fürinander
interessieren dass sie sich zuhören dass
sie eininander irgendwie zugewandt sind
und irgendwie dieser Gesprächsfaden nie
abgerissen ist ganz oft ist es ja so
dass du nicht zuhörst was ich gesagt
habe das liegt wahrscheinlich daran dass
ich dann sehr oft auf was anderes
konzentriert bin ja und das dann
praktisch
abschalte was abschalte mich
abschalte für immer ist ein Film für
jede Generation weil rührend ist witzig
lebensklug und vor allem völlig zeitlos
achentschuldige wir leben ja eigentlich
eher in so einer Zeit in der wir
wahnsinnig viele Optionen haben und auch
total darauf irgendwie so gemünzt sind
so die beste Option immer zu wählen und
das hat mich auch daran fasziniert auf
so ein paar zu gucken die wirklich so
lange zusammen geblieben sind das ist ja
eigentlich wie so der Gegenentwurf dazu
irgendwann schreibt Eva diesen Satz in
ihr Tagebuch der so viel sagt über die
die beiden und diesen wunderbaren Film
wir kommen uns wieder einmal nach all
den Ehejahren vor wie ganz am Anfang wir
lernen erst jetzt richtig zu
[Musik]
lieben am Donnerstag kommt der Film bei
uns in die Kinos sehr sehenswert und mit
Kino geht's auch hier gleich weiter mit
dem montagskino und danach um 005r
gibt's unser heute schon ein Update mit
Christopher whmann bis morgen auf
wiedersehenehen
[Musik]
schön guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter ja das unruhige
Herbstwetter setzt sich weiter fort das
bedeutet also in den nächsten Tagen
gibt's Regen und weiteren Wind Tiefs
ziehen immer wieder durch und machen es
einfach ungemütlich wir sehen uns hier
auf unser Film im Norden sind deutlich
weniger blaue Flecken zu erkennen als im
Süden es bedeutet es wird im Norden
deutlich trockener sein aber nicht
gänzlich trocken schauen wir uns die
Details an in der Nacht also in der
Nordhälfte kaum Schauer nach Süden
ziehen einige Schauer durch aber hier
Richtung schleswi-holstein sind auch
einzelne Gewitter zu erwarten die
Temperaturen gehen zurück auf 0° an den
Alpen und 9° Richtung Nordsee und das
ist die Temperaturspanne der Nacht
morgen wird's dann wieder nass von
Südwesten her kommen neue Schauer auf
aber in der Nordhälfte ist es deutlich
trockener nur Richtung Küsten müssen Sie
hier wieder mit einzelnen Gewittern
rechnen bei höchsten Temperaturen von
13° im Osten Deutschlands und 7° z.B
Richtung Vogtland die nächsten Tage am
Mittwoch ist es noch relativ trocken
erst zum Abend kommen hier im Nordwesten
neue Schauer auf bei 7 bis 12°
Donnerstag 7 bis 11° aber deutlich mehr
Regen und auch am Freitag wird's
ungemütlich teils auch mit gewi bei 6
bis 10° also ein bisschen kühler und
damit einen schönen
Abend